I was,
uh,
and I,
I am,
I'm a,
I'll just say a positional player,
but active positional player.
Uh,
so,
uh,
they had,
a purely positional player who was
a world champion,
um,
for six years.
But,
uh,
I had a active positional style and uh,
I played,
I played quite strongly a endings,
so this was my,
my advantage also,
and then a different difficult positions
which is quite seldom in more than
chess.
Uh,
so,
and I could resist in a,
in a position for other place,
probably will resign.
And I,
I was,
uh,
finding,
interesting,
uh,
interesting ideas,
how to,
how to defend difficult positions and
uh,
I could save money games so I never gave
up.
I was a stubborn as a chess player and
uh,
so I,
I tried to defend even very bad
positions and uh,
in many cases succeeded
as a,
as a personality and fighter,
you know,
and,
uh,
I don't give up if I believe,
I'm a,
I'm correct.
I'm right.
Then I've broken a.
okay.
This could be overtures boards,
it could be in life.
And a saw.
I defend my principles and in just in
just,
okay,
this is a special,
uh,
special,
how to say a characteristic when you,
when you try to find the best for
whatever position is because many
people,
they say,
okay,
this is bad.
And then they,
they lose the will to fight.
I never lost will to fight.
This is a very important,
and this is good question because many
people would,
would,
uh,
the situation,
okay,
they miss chances and then of course it,
it will spoil the rest of the game.
Um,
but,
um,
it is concerning concerning not only
special situation during the game,
but also the results of previous game
for the next,
for the next game you play.
So now in my life I,
I tried and uh,
I succeeded in many cases to forget
every single was in the past.
So of course you need to make some
analysis and not to repeat mistakes,
but it's extremely important,
uh,
to accept situation.
Like it is the real situation,
not with the salts and the regrets of
what,
what you missed.
And uh,
okay,
to mostly goal,
you'll have a winning position now
you'll have to defend difficult position
and probably,
you know,
you might lose the game.
So this shouldn't,
shouldn't be venue play when you play
chess game.
So later on might be you and a license,
then you know,
you have to see then you make some
conclusions by is a game.
And this is also really important part
for a,
for just education because a chess,
uh,
chess is getting ideas how to accept a,
how to accept a real situation and to
be,
uh,
to be objective,
to be objective and uh,
to,
to meet,
uh,
unexpected situations.
And uh,
to adapt this immediately and to start
to sink and to solve the problems,
you'll have to develop this.
So I don't think it comes from,
from your childhood,
obviously your bus.